welcome back we are here with the
amazing my friend curtis 50 jackson
um
it's valentine's day soon
how does 50 valentine
i'm not that good
they're good at valentine well
i need suggestions you can help me with
it well what is the best valentine's day
situation you've been in
well i mean i i like all types of
valentine's day i'll do a galentine's
day if someone wants to take me on a
date i'll i'm very like
game i i like being silly and like going
to play video games or do something like
eat a piece of slice of pizza on a curb
i uh
a curb and i try that i know that's not
going to go over well but
but i'm going to try that one we're
going to try that with you know the
curve and the pizza i can get both of
them
with no problem you know what i really
like the most actually
and this one for me is priceless
something made
something if you make something for
someone that to me is money can't buy
that
that's gonna probably take to next year
though yeah
they're gonna start now and next
valentine's day
i love how viral
the
picture you posted with all the money
laid out
and the word broke the irony
um
it's it's everywhere how did this idea
come about and do you enjoy
see look i love that create
yeah that was different um this is my
rent
[Laughter]
um
what came what made you come up with
that idea and do you like how it
matriculated into such a little
phenomenon well things are different now
that we've got these different social
platforms so people are communicating
through photographs your son is nine
yeah yeah and does he is he into social
media not much i'm sitting in the video
games
in the video game oh my god he's light
skinned 50.
um by the way he's absolutely stunning
what a beautiful
soulful
gorgeous young gentleman thank you i
know i haven't been called soulful
gorgeous young gym see this is the stuff
that he owned i had drewberry more say
that about you boy
he owe me he owed me big time how are
you going to start out like that isn't
it cool to like watch your kids so
become who they are like i had an
experience like i tell them if i say
something to you if i ask you something
you got to answer me right because i'm
talking to him and he's not responding
and then
i'm watching like i'll watch him play
the video game so i'm like on facetime
while he playing the game and he'll um
he just got up and do something across
the room i said yo why you do that
he looked at me he said i don't know
and i said so that's it he's like that
was my answer
he said
which is like really interesting no i'm
waiting for the moment that i can do
that i'm going to do something and
they're going to say why'd you do that
50 and i'm going to say i don't know
[Music]